bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e mi sto sparando solo
siamo ritornati ragazzi a lascio blogger
che sarebbe il gioco di anche da noi
evitarlo buongiorno anche ha detto
estatica la cosa che volevo dire che
nell'ultimo episodio di until da un rush
blog quindi questo bel gioco mi ha
dimenticato anche di dire che in realtà
questo gioco qua sarebbe collegato al
videogioco vero di hunted anche io non
ho giocato quindi non so un cazzo asca
treviso fegato addosso spal ovvero
classi massimo corpi di natale perché
belli mi stanno in culo i corvi che però
mi ci sono ricordi
ciao zio tutti i corpi del cazzo
guardi che quindi signor pupazzo non
volevo investirla una [ __ ] bakkal aida
è stato bruttissimo timori se la
famiglia è stato novi giuro su dio è
stato orribile è volato un joystick per
caso è finito gli occhi al metano ma
quella maniquis affermati e che assomma
yamane più c'è marco l'occhio ma non è
cuffiano piazzando già questi scusiamo
arrivo bene non mi sono stupito non
abbia spezzato un braccio mi dico
[Musica]
si no
che cazzo giorno nel mio braccio che non
vanno mai bene dai ragazzi sono un nuovo
pistolero non ho capito cos'è successo
vabbè danno lasca guarda guarda caso di
artisti e vabbè vabbè è sempre comunque
tranquillo che prendere un autobus a
torino basta garage blog
ora grazie a dio unsafe keep out ex lo
fai io non sto facendo niente mi portano
vari dai e borja la eva banda bardò
fatta perchè non c'è lo ferma la bassa
software no niente cancelli si aprono
puoi restare chiuso cambiano sbatter di
fermo grazie ma che che sta urlando che
lo sentono
ciao
un abbraccio non può
non muore devo fare non credo no è morto
un attimo un attimo una un secondo porca
vacca che se dove la sposò il sì ma che
ci parla l'altro john mica testate di
video non carica mi gratifica pedata in
faccia alla carica
la rega posso farmi la domanda ma
semplice per chi ha giocato tanti da un
no ma anche il dow è così ma perché sono
ho fatto bene a non giocarlo sa tanto di
morire perché allora è netto di
prosciutto corso grazie è un pool di
parma ce l'hai colonia di barman abbasso
i meccanici sentire gradisci del
prosciutto che in teoria è pieno non
gradisce prosciutto valcava capra
posso farvi una domanda non è che vi
attivate tutti quanti insieme vero mi
devo sparare per forza mista di 59 beh
se adesso mi spunta o sei stato no no no
no vi prego o le montagne russe di nuovo
no a questi gianfermi soffermi e ho
visto è ce lo dico alla maestra timori
nel dubbio ragazzi dovete stare fermi ve
lo chiedo per favore no eh vabbè che
cazzo è sofia 6
una domanda di coli tutti quelli dietro
spariti immagino poi grazie a dio che il
gioco ma si chiudono tutte come minimo
quanto scommettete che cazzo
[Musica]
il bambino ha fatto no e lo sapevo che
si chiudevano le corde bastano già
arrivati basta tuttavia mia zia ci dava
almeno 100 euro porcaccia lacca la
smette chi è che il mona che sbatte la
porta lì sarei sono rispuntano gianni
cazzola up di sedano fammi vedere cosa
c'è in offrirmi le doppiezze perfetto
salve lei non è l'animale domestico di
casa vero però stai calma devi stare
calma calma proprio ai box di gas che
non ho capito un box perché lei cuore
cioè problemi ora ganon crepano un'ora e
mezza brancolando giu
[Musica]
tuo brutta [ __ ] ai grandi progressi ha
detto un recupero totale molto presto ma
tu sei tutto scemo maturò gatti
maledetto tag la tipa è morta
l'importante è quello celebre di meno
brema ma così stampa che prendo sempre
di meno spiegatemelo bastati corvi che
palle sembra che si sostituì avete frate
file europa portateli via e cazzulini la
mostra è la viola non lo capisco c'è
veramente leggero non capisco perchè
perchè i corpi perché i ricordi perché
quel cazzo perché i corvi cosa ci hanno
ricordi che problema c'è salve sto posto
nokia è una domanda è semplice ma poi
trovarmi cosa c'è porca marca line
frattempo niente la sosta ma non
dobbiamo mica entrare là dentro
cos'è sta roba dove si è cos'è sto posto
perché ogni volta ci sono costi sempre
più brutti no no no no frate no frate
che ti volti alzo le mani frati rialzo
di 1 insomma ti faccio male ti faccio
male fratello ti faccio male chi ti
uccido ti prego
crepa passaggio basta ai quarti di
secolo ricordati in bocca per morire se
sembrava tanto verde è la prima volta
cioè l'alito che parlamento
com'è che i morti le tipe tu mi ero
dimenticato la sua statica di rimorchio
è morto grazia di dio ma ragazzi oa ma
c'è un problema non crepa la gente che
problemi che cosa cazzo da fare ma che
vanno al serio sono si affaccia oggi o
per farli fuori tutti
jobs il brutto come la fame almeno farli
fuori decreta porca [ __ ] volè mi
volevi pure tu su ca
mica neanche in ghisa lin fast and
furious fa test dice basta basta sempre
meglio perfetto però credo vi sia
piaciuto conclude episodio è stato e
quanto bello rigiocherà sta roba però
per oggi basta sono proprio contento
della macchina i capelli sono contenti
mi vedete che felicità scrivi ragazzi
spero vi sia piaciuto cose non si
capisce un momento non mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e camilo trascrizione
ce ne sono se vi siete lì ci mettiamo un
prossimo vinto bene ragazzi